this morning on the dish Mason Hereford
on Monday the New Orleans chef was
nominated for his first James Beard
Award it's the latest remarkable feat
for the chef who has rewritten all the
rules of modern dining Jamie wax has
been following the chef's story by the
time we first met Mason Herefords just
over two years ago he had already shaken
up the culinary scene not only in New
Orleans but beyond Bon Appetit had named
his eatery Turkey and the wolf America's
best new restaurant and suddenly this
humble little sandwich shop had become
the toast of the town
God 40 seats you think that you're gonna
serve 40 people three times and that's
gonna be your day it's a whole new
curveball when 400 people walk in on a
Saturday diners flock here for Herefords
unique take on comfort food classics
like deviled eggs with fried chicken
skins collard green melts with pickled
cherry pepper dressing and coleslaw and
wedge salads
it's been called stoner food what do you
like that also reminds you that just
because something is a casual version of
food it doesn't make it anything less to
enjoy you know as a diner a number of
the items are based on Herefords
childhood like the bologna sandwich but
you've never had Bologna like this which
is sourced from pork raised on a farm in
Mississippi as the filling sandwich the
bread specially baked using a friend's
recipe there's a healthy spreading of
Dukes Mayo dig splits apple cider
vinegar in there and makes it super
delicious mustard made from the recipe
of another friend a bunch of sure that's
on top of that we call it shred us you
think it's clever the next step is gonna
be that Bologna
it's seared off with the nice melty
cheese and topped off with house-made
chips which are brined in vinegar for 24
hours and fried each morning one big
handful say if you're gonna pick it up
and eat it the first move you gotta do
is make it so you could fit in your
mouth so the crush can I eat this get in
there bro
hmm you won't be surprised to learn that
this irreverent chef has followed an
unusual path to success is this what you
wanted to do your whole life now I you
know I always wanted to be a
professional roller blader and is that
really funny laughs are very Herod did
go to college then he followed a friend
to New Orleans I thought I wanted to be
something like ecology you know but it
turns out that the service industry in
New Orleans can suck you in he got a job
at the upscale restaurant Coquette
working his way up to chef de cuisine I
love going out and eating fine dining I
do it every chance I can I just wanted
to have more fun and I wanted fun to be
more of a guarantee and I got this hang
on the wall so hair furred open turkey
and the wolf to have a place for him and
his friends to work in as it's clear to
see on Instagram hair furred has been on
quite a roll and just this week the
sandwich King became even closer to
royalty earning a James Beard Award
nomination in the category Best Chef
south watch on the side hair furred has
also opened to breakfast focused
restaurant
Molly's rise and shine which he runs
with his wife Lauren agudo this is kind
of our piece of Americana breakfast
sandwich it's got sausage fried hash
brown American cheese grilled onions and
then ketchup this is sort of one of the
weirder dishes
it's a deviled egg tostada with peanut
salsa and refried red bean pickled
peppers onions cilantro this smells
unbelievable yeah that one's a man's one
of my babe but as New Orleans battles
one of the country's largest outbreaks
of the coronavirus both of Herefords
restaurants have been forced to close
for the time being this week millions of
restaurant workers suddenly lost their
jobs baby you can help he's been using
social media to raise money to support
the restaurant industry while
encouraging customers to slow the spread
of the virus with his one of
take on shelter-in-place hereford has
always used his platform to promote
other restaurants he believes also
deserve attention and to poke fun at
himself and you say things like come eat
some
overrated food you got a sign on the
exit here that says this place sucks
there's a sign on the door that says
people hate us on Yelp yeah these are
all facts we try to keep a sense of
humor about it cheers guys
go group cheers here we know so many
things have have gone our way and we
just we have to be realistic
group hug guys and we don't want people
to think that we knew that it was ever
gonna happen because there's no way to
ever plan for this for CBS this morning
Saturday Jamie whacks New Orleans
fantastic Rolling Stone